ようこそ
肇社長のチャンネルユウユこいつも
ゲームズ一定を始めたかと思われると思いますがその通りですよ
数えてそのゲーム実況チャンネルバーン作るわけでもなく本当にも自分のしたいように
やっていかせていただきます勘違い室内でくださいな
そんな誰かと加工何かこう組織にこうやれって言われてるわけじゃないんでもう本当に
したくてやらせていただいてるんでそこら辺勘違いしないで下さいよ
やっぱ試みが来てるじゃないです j 物1超のビッグ売れる
俺はね大きなビッグウェーブにね乗って舐めの利用したいわけじゃなに話してねそう
いう話じゃないんですけど本当にそいつはいい
やっぱ登録さんもおかげさまで増えてきたのでいろんなことに挑戦していこうかなと
思ってます
魔獣なチャンネルなんで
何してもいいと思うんですけど
今回やるのは
こちらの
サイレントヒルの2の方ですねっ
ちょっとほらぽいんで
結構照明も暗いとしてお供で日目でやってるんで
そのビビってるんですよ
やったことないんですよちょっとだけしたけどぜひ皆さんとこのね
ほなぁな感じをね共有できたらいいと思います
いくぜ
サイレントキルですよ静岡ですよ静岡
というわけで
2からやっていこうと思います
3あるかわかんないんだよね
new 音をそれぞれ様子見です
様子見てできたら3をやるって感じです
いきなりゲーム実況とびっくりしたでしょ
マウスが映っ
ポッ
という僕もであるニューゲームですね
easy easy
物が過ぎてこうもたオチャメチャってしてもきっとみんな怒るとんね
もう損をさせずにもうイース上でもいいずに行きますか
[音楽]
主人公です
いけばいいんです
9話目のゲームだかな
[音楽]
トイレですねー
あなたみたい
[音楽]
絶叫つに鼻をかむというちょっと楽しんでくださいね
久住を得て言えましたん
だったろう
ん
はいと言うしねこの今彼が入ったべアリーっていうのはもうちょっと先にもうちょっと
ちょっとだけやったんで
女あるって言うのはこの人の大きさだったらしいですね
の
こうなんか3年前に亡くなっちゃって
その3連覇インター間てた奥さんから手紙が来たんですよこの人はて人
でもその身リードに手紙が来たから
何だろうと思うので
委員長その
手紙の手元を探しににこのサイレントヒルってますねいった感じです
思います分からないですけど
私だったん
さえなれ青
いえい
[音楽]
promise to do
二人で会う約束された punta
[音楽]
あー飛ばしちゃったいいでしょ
いいんですよ
8していきません
それにこの車に地図があります
先にちょっと行ったんだよ
ほら兄家
これいいスって地図見て
今この何かここの右素直でいるんで
ぞんどん松の方に入っちゃいって感じですね
水1勢
罰防弾で走れますん
いい感じだ
を
うわああったします
ませんちょっと実はこの辺も3回目なんですよ
通りの先輩して3回目なんで
ちょっと無理やりリアクションします
うわぁ
今のままわざとなリアクションです
自腹か何も出ないんですよ
多分
1回あったからわかるんですよね
bgm は怖いですね
移動はいん
井戸です
[音楽]
ここでねー西武ができるんですよ
奇妙な感じを受けると思う
マイ西武です
[音楽]
j
思ってるれビビれないっしょ
小太刀3対0分
[音楽]
おもんですねぇ
bgm が変わった
女
おかわいい
を
なんでもないです
四球と見えない失礼はいサビ
はいこれなぜ頭を打つ気をドラッグすればいいかなんですからすまない
甘味強くしなかったなぁ
実用
菜園と中には子どもも四球を8日
イズベストバイをへ
アンジェあうっ
hag cbs パー5
運営ソンミドウォンバーをにキャメせ
ん
いっぱいよし
海鮮きゅっぱるした様へ俺もそうも
ウズしています
てくださチャーンスが変になってるの久津いんんん
メッセージ
ase ハードワークスペイン前
練習数
bb
愛知のちゃすとふぁー e 5票である
足袋型分
now i よ
when
レジェス歳上でおける江別店量じゃない
なんか曲げでチャーミーの声
街にブース8
こわ e
ナム近4走
4 s 愛知そういう
それが目あります
大切な人12選
です多分
抜きに3枚マアム
あいみんうまいまあ分
演奏を分析してい
ウィさあ米フォードはにまずは費やう
検査員で水が父と兄を探せるこいつ
ダブ3 e
英智なきゃ w
4 p ファインダー
いや t 4
俺はここでこの女子
仲間にしようと思ったんですけど
そんなに世代んだろう
なぜ
終始加えていません
is
ほらなんかこうなんなんでしょ
つ一緒に来た方が設定安全だと思うんですけれども
来てくれないですね
no 理想は同じあれなんでちょっと炎などはここでお別れというわけです一旦
一人でん
いきます
山田しばらく出てこないな多分
進みます
あの女子祝ってしまう1本蜜って言ってたんで
町には
簡単に行けると思います
がべきでしたーー
方が音が怖いんです
やばいなぁ
実はこれ3回プレイしてるんですけどまたそのモンスターと合ってないんですよます
ねっ
正直出てきたら
どうなるんですかです
わかんないですけど
難波ないなぁ
を
させ物っぽい色
おおあ恋
まだ来ない人生はしたくないです
なんかアイテムとか取らなくていいのかなぁ
といった方がいい気もするんですけどすみます
走り方ろん
かわいいだ3ん
ん
強い加え
バーカ家ですね
ああ
雰囲気が鍋
しばらくか全然来ないし何も
お願います
ターンですと
ん
看板があったので
もう関根やるんだから作るんですよ
フラワー沿ってお花屋さんですね
プライアソップ
入れないです
5号から
ラバーショップ生えないんで特に
いいと思います
んですけど
来月も入れないに入っ
怖い怖い怖いっ
何もないですね
いいよねコツだよ
そろそろ来るぞ多分
をしいっ
これはツナとか
するか
[音楽]
した
monsters アイスかー
シャア
力でねじ伏せてありますよ
おっ
ウェバー
と違う
こっちの後的倍って感じですね
ん
家の跡等のあとちの後覚えが
こっ違う
こっちがこっちに向かったのかん
こちらは少々です
赤い nasa の1000ポイントなんですよを
栄養ドリンクですね
多分回復大丈夫的なアレだとですがん
森こぼす年
今日はここまでにしようと思います
一気に進んでも見づらいと思うんで
を
熊栄養ドリンクがあっ
というのを取れたえーるあドリンクスものを作らん
という感じなんで
次は
こっからスタートする多分さっき問題たんで
次はもうスターくると思う
そんな感じでパートつ
他の書類政治ください
ただに再生リストとか何かや作ると思うんで
よかったら
ゲーム実況の訪問
も飲みに行くんで見てやってください
じゃあな